hey everyone
thank you very much for joining us i am
so excited to kick off the diablo
segment
of our show and i am honored to be here
on behalf of all of our diablo teams
to share the news and updates we have in
store for you today
we've got a lot of diablo to cover and i
hope you'll agree with me that it's a
great time
to be a member of this community all
right let's kick things off with diablo
4.
we first shared our game with you during
blizzcon of 2019
and we've been truly humbled by your
response
we've kept in touch through quarterly
updates and sincerely appreciate the
thoughts
and valuable feedback you've provided as
we unveil
more and more of the game and share in
its development
after all diablo belongs to you as much
as it belongs to
us most recently we teased and updated
to our campfire screen
and savvy fans of course understood that
we meant
more than just the character lighting
and fire visual effects
that's right today we're happy to
announce a brave new soul
joining the barbarian the sorcerer and
the druid
on this dangerous journey back to
sanctuary
a class is one of the most exciting
things you can announce in a diablo game
this one is especially exciting to me as
it's a re-envisioning of one of the
first classes to ever appear in the
series
let's have a look
[Music]
there is justice within the light
but you have to be patient
mercy and granted
mercy what are you doing here
this is not the time but this
is confession
and i have sinned
i was a thief who stole
from those more fortunate
i strayed from your light
and found my trade in the shadows
they call it murder
i say job well
done
[Music]
i am a thief a heretic
a murderer father
will akara save me
hmm mark our light
but those monsters were a scourge upon
my frog
and you
you were the answer to their prayers
then we are settled and you owe me
the name you see is
thank the heavens for you
heavens i assure you father
the heavens didn't send me
um
uh
[Music]
just the sound of that ear getting
pierced by the hook is so brutal i feel
like it's going to haunt me for a long
time
i've been a huge fan of the rogue ever
since the original diablo
even seeing them come back as npcs and
mercenaries
in diablo 2's rogue encampment served as
a great bridge between the games
with the setting of diablo 4 being a
larger world than we've
ever played them before we're excited to
show you
not just what the successors to the
original rogues in the series
have been up to since the fall of their
order but also what some of the other
rogues in the world of sanctuary might
look like
the mantra for diablo iv has been
customization
first and the road takes us to a whole
new level
from the beginning the rogue has been an
incredibly
flexible class able to adapt to any
situation
our goal is to let you create the kind
of rogue
that you want to play whether it's an
unrivaled archer
modeled after the original sisterhood or
a cloak and dagger rogue from the
darkest alleys of caldeum in diablo 4
you will have the freedom to create the
rogue that you imagine
by customizing the looks the background
and the play style of your character
please stick around for our segment
later today
where i'll be joined by other members of
the diablo 4 team
to share a closer look at the rogue
class as well
as some of the open world gameplay that
we're bringing to the game
spoilers those severed ears are not just
for show
but diablo 4 is not the only diablo game
we're talking about today
if you're looking for an authentic
diablo experience
on mobile we've got you covered diablo
immortal has
everything you'd expect from a triple a
action rpg
from the visceral combat and epic loot
to an all-new story
bridging the gap between the events of
diablo 2 and diablo 3.
later today you can join the immortal
team where they'll talk about some of
the things they've learned
from their recent alpha test and what's
next for the game
but that's still not all we have one
last bit
of very exciting diablo news to cover
when you hear us talk about the classes
the items or the stories
of the early diablo games you may have
picked up
on the absolute reverent tone we reserve
for that golden era of diablo
maybe you share that love of the
classics and just hearing us talk about
them
makes you want to take on mephisto or
bale one more time
or maybe even for the first time after
all
some of our favorite moments happened a
long time ago
and not just in sanctuary years
if so we have a special surprise for you
today
let's check it out
you know what i seek were these the
demons
though this beyond focus tower it may
yet be
your greatest moment
[Music]
oh
[Music]
hmm
not even them
after more than 20 years the dark
wanderer
has returned and once again he travels
east always east diablo 2
is a landmark game for blizzard diablo 2
resurrected
is a full hd remaster
of both the original game and the
expansion
lord of destruction it takes the 2d
sprite-based classic that we love and
brings it into the present
in 3d utilizing up-to-date graphical
rendering
and lighting technologies it also
includes modernizing
all 27 minutes of cinematics
recreated shot for shot with the
explicit
intention of preserving both the look
and the pacing of the original movies
blizzard
has a long history of games that we're
proud of
and when we think about diablo 2 we
think about it
as a definitive pillar in our foundation
now it's funny to think that some of you
weren't even born when d2 was released
which
makes it all the more important that we
deliver an authentic experience
wherever you play we want everyone
to relive their memories or experience
the game for the very first time
on their platform of choice and so we're
excited
to bring diablo 2 resurrected to pc
and console along with cross progression
and for those of you who are in love
with the original
and you just wish it worked more
seamlessly on modern computers
you can bring back all of that nostalgia
exactly as you remember
and enjoy the game in its original 2d
form
much like we did with starcraft
remastered obviously
there's a lot to talk about later today
diablo speedrunner mr lama will host a
round table
with members of the development team on
the dedicated diablo channel
if you are a diablo 2 fan i encourage
you to take a look